Hey guys, it's Benefits from GE Tracker
here. And today's video, we're going to
talk about how to profit from
collectibles.
Now, this is one of my favorite topics
uh that I've that I've been wanting to
talk about for quite some time.
But, I've kind of I've kind of held off
to it. And it's going to be
it's going to be a very simple video in
regards to any kind of lessons or
educational kind of things you guys can
learn off of this. If you're already
flipping
uh dragon warhammers, cloaks,
third age long swords, then this video
is
not really for you. It's really for
players who are still just in the
beginner stage of flipping, still
getting their feet wet, they're still
trying to learn how to find different
items to find. And hopefully, in this
video, if you're a collector yourself,
maybe you'll learn something off of
this. And hopefully, you can try and
profit off of the collection that you've
already started. And continue that
overall in the long run, so you can try
and profit off of that. Or if you're
brand new to flipping, and you like the
idea of collecting, or you just want to
find a different way to make money,
then this may work for you as well.
All right. So, let me start off by
talking about the different types of
categories
that I've just kind of personalized.
I've you know, I put up my own name for
these. I mean, you guys can name them
whatever you want. But, I have four
categories
that that which are flatline,
times two double up, holiday, and
valuables. Now, there's also another
category in here that's another type of
collectibles that's not shown. And those
would be anything untradeable. Like um
random events. You could collect the
frog to chuck you could collect buckets
of chocolate milk. That's that's
non-tradeable. So, you can kind of
convert things to non-tradeable items.
And
you you kind of lose out on that. So,
there's there's no reason for me to
include that category in here. And the
only category I'm actually going to talk
about
specifically in this video is a double
up category, cuz that's where you can
actually make the most money. The other
categories,
um
unless you're a high-level merchant and
you are very comfortable flipping third
age long swords, alleys, dragon
warhammers, or cloaks,
then I would stay away from those in
terms of collecting.
Okay. So, first off, we have our
flatline category. And this is anything
that
basically high-volume items are going to
fit into this category. And they're
going to be anywhere between
1 to 10 GP.
Um these items are going to have
razor-thin margins, and they're going to
be kind of slow to obtain for profit.
So, if the price is around 3 GP,
then you're obviously going to try and
get it for like two.
But,
you're going to want to look at the
graphs to see how often those kind of
move and if they move at all. Uh if
they're going to kind of determine
whether or not you're going to pick this
item to kind of collect in the long
term. But, you should also keep in mind
that if you're going to go this route in
terms of a flatline item to collect,
then you should have no expectations to
make any money whatsoever. But, you can
try and do so. But, it's just going to
be not worthwhile to try and pursue.
And then next, we have our holiday
items. And like the flatline items,
there's not really much to say about
this. So, we're just going to kind of
briefly go over it.
And these are basically, as the title
says, any holiday item that comes out
during any of those holiday events. This
could be Christmas, Easter, Halloween,
etc. and any other events that they may
put out during the year.
Uh the the downside and the biggest
downside to this is that the J Mods mass
spawn them each year. So, every time
that event comes up, they're going to
mass spawn all of the previous items
from the previous years and the items
from this year. No, no, not the items
from this year. I apologize.
Uh but, they're going to they're going
to spawn all the items from the previous
years. And that's going to always
decrease the value of those items.
And they didn't want to see the rares
damage the economy to the old school.
So, that's why they do this each year
and for obvious reasons. Just like
flatline, I'm not going to go too much
into this. And if you guys want to kind
of pursue this, I would do this on your
own risk. And finally, we have our times
two double up. Now, this category
what's beautiful about this category is
the title really does fit. And it's it's
so true. I mean, some of these items you
can make even more than double your
investment. Um so, I don't know if
you're not doing this, if you're not a
collectible, or if you're not if you're
not collecting items, or if you're not
pursuing items like this, if you're like
kind of a a low-level merchant, I
honestly don't know why you're not. The
margins on this are
are crazy. I mean, you can look at the
top mar on top chart that's from the
weekly graph. And on the bottom chart,
that's another from a yearly graph. So,
all these items are going to kind of
behave differently. So, those two charts
are different items. But, I have
three charts I'm going to go over with
you guys uh filling this category up, so
I can show you different time frames. Uh
some items are going to be long-term.
And then some items are going to be
short-term. And then I think one of
them's going to be kind of like a mix in
the in the middle.
So, the positives about the times two
double up category is that the entry
level is really low. Almost anyone can
start flipping these items, and they're
fairly profitable. You're going to find
margins you're going to find
flips that are going to kind of mirror
or kind of match some players who are
who have like 50 million to work with
and are flipping, I don't know, armadyl
god swords or stuff like that. You're
going to find similar profit um you're
going to find similar flips in terms of
the total profit made depending on how
much you how much you had invested and
um
type of item and how much the how much
the margin is. It always varies. These
items are going to be very different
from each other. And so many items out
there that you guys it's it's almost
impossible you guys can't find an item
for yourselves.
Um now, these items are also going to be
normally skill-based. So, that's another
it's another clue for you guys to kind
of look in that kind of direction. These
items are going to kind of be involved
with anything that has to do with
skills. Herblore is a big one. That's
actually a really big one. Herblore
makes a lot of money.
Kind of just like the the whole area of
it. You can decant potions. You can you
can flip the secondaries.
Um
there's a lot of money to be made in
that skill specifically.
Um you could do runes. Runes are another
one as well. Runecrafting. Not as big of
a margin.
Um and then there's some other specific
items that are very niche that I can't
really say. But, I'm going to show you a
graph of one of those. So, hopefully you
guys can get some idea.
Um so, like I said earlier, these are
going to be short and long-term. And
then these items are almost immune to
updates. Almost immune to updates. So,
you if you find these items, these are
like
these are like the unicorns of all items
in RuneScape.
And in Old School RuneScape. All right.
Here we are.
We have our graph here. And for obvious
reasons, we're not going to show the
actual item.
Cuz I don't want to kind of influence
you guys to pick a specific item. Hope
you guys can do that on your own. You
guys learn a lot
um by finding these items on your own. I
mean, you guys can use the high-volume
tool on our website. That's also a great
tool for finding items like this.
But, in terms of actually looking at the
graph and seeing whether or not this is
something that you could collect, that's
what we're going to talk about right
here. So, every single time that you
look at an item at first hand if you're
going to try and collect it, is you're
going to want to look at the yearly
graph.
Now, you're going to want to look for
this specific pattern.
Um you guys can call them cadiers,
hills, spikes, mountains, roller
coaster, whatever. It doesn't matter
what terminology you give these.
All you want to see is that it kind of
moves up and it moves down periodically.
It doesn't have to happen very often.
But, it but it just has to show that
pattern. And there's other items that
behave a little bit quicker. I'm going
to go over that in a in a different item
different graph.
But, if we can see here that this item
is behaving in that similar pattern.
So, what we're going to start doing is
we're going to start moving down the
timeline from quarter to monthly to
weekly to see how where it's going at
the current point in time. And so, right
off the bat, I can tell
that it has been moving up in recent
time. But, now it's starting to go down
a little bit. So, this might be an
opportunity for me to start putting my
investments in early to try and get a
price at a lower amount. So, what I mean
by that if if I look at the yearly graph
here, I can see that at times at peak
amount, it can sometimes reach 140 100
156,
126,
70. And then it goes all the way down to
22, 24. So, I mean, you guys can picture
this. I mean, obviously if you get like
100,000 of this item
and at 24 GP and you were able to sell
it for 156 GP, that is bank made. That
that's that's a great flip. That's
exactly what you want to go for. And in
terms of collecting it in the long run,
you're going to want to
kind of divvy it up determine how easy
it was for you to obtain this item.
Um was it really slow? So, an example of
an item like that would be basically any
bronze items.
Bronze items are just
difficult to obtain
uh at a good price. And they're even
harder to sell for profit. They're just
they're just so difficult to sell.
Everyone wants to sell them. So, if
you're going to try and collect bronze
items, just
good luck with that. I think that whole
thing is just a money pit. I don't think
you're really going to make a lot of
money. But, again, looking at this
graph, this is how you look at it. So,
you start off at the yearly time frame.
And then you start moving down to the
you start moving down the timeline to
see where it's headed. And then we have
Let's go over this item next. So, this
item, not so much of that massive big
drops here and there.
But, it is showing that pattern.
Uh that little pattern of just going up
and down, up and down. That's what we
want to look for.
So, let's see. And then, if we look
Let's actually look at the price again
cuz uh this is going to be very
important for the last graph. The last
graph I want you guys to pay attention
to the to the pricing. So, with this one
we can see that it goes from 20 to 160
on the price falling graph.
And if we look at this one, it goes from
120 to 200. So, okay. So, these are kind
of low-priced items. So, these are very
low entry items for a lot of you guys
out there. But, if you're a little bit
of a high-level merchant, then maybe
this next item, this last one after
this, is going to be a little bit more
in your area.
But, again, we're just going to look
down at the timeline for each of the
graphs.
Okay.
Doesn't look to be changing too much.
Now, this is what's really important.
So, now that I've gone down the
timeline, I can tell that
in the long run, it doesn't really
it doesn't really There's not really a
direction it moves. It doesn't really
skyrocket. It doesn't really move down
any given point in time. It just kind of
does its own thing. It just kind of
moves all over the place. And that's
good for short-term flipping. If you If
you want to flip short-term, you want to
get this done right away, this is what
you want to look for. If you've gone
down the timeline, you haven't really
seen anything much, but then you look at
this,
there you go. This is something that you
could flip probably during your day.
You know, you're sitting at the Grand
Exchange, you want to flip some items.
This is exactly what we want to do. And
then, you would obviously favorite this
item so it can show up on your
dashboard. And then, you can start
monitoring it over time. And then,
you'll become like an expert on kind of
patterns. But, something like this
with an item that doesn't fluctuate as
often, this isn't going to be an item
that you're going to kind of look for
patterns for, but it's just something
that you can maybe consistently go back
to and make a lot of money like every
day. Kind of like that thing that uh a
lot of a lot of noob flippers like to to
flip Zora scales because it's
it's very easy, um very quick.
This could be another item just like
that. These items are very easy to
obtain, has a high volume, and uh
margins are great, guys. I mean, look at
that. This This is just That's
fantastic. I mean, this is a great way
to start your day if you're brand-new
merchant and stuff like that. So, what
do we go to this item here?
Now,
again, make sure you're looking at the
price. Look at the price of this one. We
It goes all the way down to 70k,
and it can go all the way up to 325k.
Now, keep in mind, this is the yearly
timeframe. So, it's going to take the
average price
between those timeframes. So, it's not
going to go It's not going to show the
highest priced item that was sold on
this yearly graph. So, that that price
could have easily gone up to like 500k.
Um
it could have. So, that's one thing to
keep in mind. But, again, we can see on
this one it does have that pattern.
Doesn't matter how long the distance is.
You guys can see the distance here
between this bump here and this one over
here. It does not matter. All you want
to see is that pattern of just
consistent up and down.
Um and that's what we see here. So,
we're going to go ahead and go down the
timeline to see how it's behaving.
I think my computer's a little bit slow.
Okay.
All right.
So, with this item,
now, this is This is an item
that I actually This is one of my
favorite collectibles. And this is why I
kind of want to show you guys because
it's I mean, the margins are pretty big.
And um
it's just a fun item for me to collect.
If you're a collector, then you I mean,
you would understand. You have your
items that you like to hoard and
collect. Uh this is one of my items.
Something I like to collect. But, we can
see with this one, it doesn't really
move all that often
in the short timeframe. We can see it
does It did here
during this daytime frame. It did move a
lot. But, this is unusual for this item.
So,
I should have been online today
monitoring this and try to kind of
profit off of this because
this massive gap this often during the
day
is very unlikely for this item. But, as
I can see,
there was a lot of money to be made.
So, with an item like this, where it's
not so clear in terms of how it behaves,
this is your long-term item.
Now, like when I showed you during the
times two double-up category page,
if you go back to that, you're going to
see that it was either short-term or
long-term. Now, these two items
right here
are both long-term items. These are both
long-term flips that you don't really
try and flip in a day
or a week. These are things that you
kind of hoard on to and hold on to These
are the These are things you kind of
hold on to
hoping for their price to go up.
But, they should go up.
So,
so something like this,
what you're going to want to do
is you're going to just want to pay
attention to the graph overall. So,
recently, we can see that it's spiked up
and it's kind of going down a little
bit. But, if we looked at the daily
timeframe, it's still acting very weird.
So, what I could do
is
going off of my experience with this
item, I could start putting in my values
in for the price that I usually get this
item at. And since it's kind of
fluctuating like this, it's kind of
acting very strange.
This is kind of telling me that it may
actually go back up in price again.
It kind of Yeah, okay. So, we're looking
at this weekly timeframe.
Um
so, if I'm looking at this yearly
timeframe, and then I look at this daily
timeframe, this kind of weird scattering
scattering is going to is showing me
that it's going back up again,
especially since the orange line, which
is the sell sell price line, that's
moving up. And then, we can see at the
very bottom up that it's kind of like
spiking at different moments
in terms of the amount traded. So, it
may be someone that's dumping their
items to try and get for uh a good
price. It may be someone that's trying
to manipulate it to try and push the
item back up.
But, in terms of actually putting a
price for this, this is actually
something that I would not do yet.
Um so, I do take that back. This is an
item that I would probably hold on to.
Um
or I would hold on to my offer at the
GE. And then, if I if I did have any
items held on to this, this is the point
where I would start selling it off. But,
again,
depending upon your own goals,
how much you want to hoard, how easy
this is to obtain,
um this isn't exactly a high-volume
item, so I can't exactly get 10,000 of
these in one go. So, that's kind of like
the the part of the struggle with this
one in terms of long-term collecting.
So, you have to determine whether or not
if you can sell off
So, let's say we have 100 of this item.
Um and it's reached to 300k. We could We
could sell 80 of those and then keep uh
keep 20 of those and assuming that the
next time one of these spikes happens,
we're going to at least have more than
100, maybe like 120. So, then when we
sell another 80, we'll have 40 left, and
so on and so on. And that's how you kind
of progressively move on with these
things.
So, yeah. With an item like this, guys,
this is going to be a long-term item,
long long-term price. You're going to
want to
if you're going to If you're going to do
an item like this, you're going to have
to keep in mind that you may be holding
on to this for for weeks. You may be
investing on to this for weeks if it's
something that you uh you really want to
collect. Um and then, you're hoping to
kind of like sell back for money. So, I
mean, if you look at this timeframe
here,
right during here,
this is a is a massive amount of time
between
um
the last spike. So, I mean, this this
could very well happen as well.
With an item like this, this is 100k to
300k. So,
you know, with with the the higher value
an item goes, the more likely the more
likely it is that you may be holding on
to it for longer.
So, a good example of that would be
third-age item. So, if you want to If
you want to predict that a third-age
item is going to go back up, and you
want to start hoarding those,
it may be sometime before it reaches a
price point that you predicted, or maybe
not at all. Cuz I mean, third-age
third-age items are going to be a whole
lot more risky than this item.
This is This is a fairly stable item,
fairly uh
fairly independent from any game
updates. So, I've I've watched many game
updates, and this thing hasn't really
moved at all.
All right, guys. I think that's going to
be the end of the video. If you guys
have any questions, be sure to leave a
comment down below to give me your
thoughts. If you guys like this video,
be sure to show your support by leaving
a like and subscribe for future content.
Other than that, guys, though, good luck
merching, and until next time.
[Music]